cela fait longtemps je n'ai pas fait un
petit tour de magie dans une intro voilà
qui est mieux n'est-ce pas clément ne me
dis pas que tu as fait exprès de pas
faire le cut au bon moment au montage
pour que les gens découvrent les secrets
de mes tours de magie les amis l'odyssée
une vidéo chauloux mais j'ai trop envie
de la faire parce que j'ai découvert
hier c'est très bizarre
il ya une chaîne qui s'appelle sympa ok
je passe vous connaissez elle a quand
même plus d'un million d'abonnés et sur
cette chaîne c'est que des vidéos
extrêmement plus tacler qui propose des
ordres de quiz comme par exemple
découvre si tu peux passer le test d'
agent spécial du fbi mois lucas hochart
ma carrière elle fait couci couça couci
couça réutiliser ce terme s'il vous
plaît en 2018 alors j'aimerais bien
celui-là mais arrière et savoir si en
cas de pénurie youtube je peux me
reconvertir facilement et rejoint les
rangs du npa alors je vous propose
consommons face quelques-uns de ces
tests de la chaîne sympa c'est parti
vous attention top secret mais c'est
quand même sur youtube et ça fait 2
millions de vues bon découvre si tu peux
passer le test d' agent spécial du fbi
être agent spécial du fbi y allèrent des
emplois les plus difficiles à obtenir
selon les statistiques moins de 5% des
candidats sont acceptés mais moi ma
communauté ont fait partie de ces 5 %
gamin répondre à un certain nombre de
questions peut montrer si le candidat a
un potentiel naturel pour développer une
pensée créative et des compétences de
raisonnements logiques sociales
jusque-là ferais-tu partie des rares
personnes à réussir le test
ok qu'est la première énigme je veux
tout savoir tout pilule un tueur en
série kidnapper des gens et leur faisait
prendre une sur deux pilules
l'une était inoffensive et l'autre
étaient toxiques quelle que soit la
pilule prise par la victime
le tueur en série prenez l'autre chaque
fois les victimes mouret et le tueur en
série sur vivez comment le tueur avait
t-il toujours la pilule inoffensive
oh la la au delà du temps
y'avait ya aucune pilule qui était allé
au cumul était toxique c'était l'effet
placebo on va dire que c'est l'effet
placebo inversée étant persuadé qu'il
est tombé sur la mauvaise le mec morts
pire théorie réponse les deux pilules
étaient inoffensives vieille le poison
étaient dans le vert d'eau que les
victimes buvait recalés ouais bon après
on a le droit de se tromper une question
tu vois on peut qu avant j'en ai bien
espacé palace maps ou sinon plus quoi
boisson un homme et une femme sont allés
au restaurant pour dîner pendant qu'ils
attendaient le plat principal elle a
commandé cinq boissons avec des glaçons
qu'elle faisait très chaud puisqu'elle
était assoiffé la femme en a vu quatre
en même temps tandis que l'homme en a bu
seulement une
après un moment l'homme est tombé malade
est mort les médecins ont affirmé que
toutes les boissons et est empoisonnée
pourquoi la femme est elle encore
vivante quand l'homme était mort
laissez moi une minute
[Musique]
ok je sais cette femme a voulu tuer son
mari pour toucher l'assurance vie elle
est donc responsable du poison présents
dans chaque verre et dans l'intestin de
son mari a décidé de prendre un antidote
avant de voir les boissons regarder la
réponse le poison était dans les glaçons
c'est exactement ce que j'ai dit des
genres juste quelques lettres qui
changent comme la fin un but très
rapidement les glaçons n'ont pas eu le
temps de fondre l'homme quant à lui a vu
très lentement et le poison a fondu dans
sa boisson ouais ouais c'est vrai c'est
une explication parmi les autres mais si
je puis me permettre
on dirait pas les énigmes que tu
racontes en colo c'est quand il est bien
tard et quand tu fais chier vraiment un
groupe de potes magnétophone imagine la
scène suivante
un homme a été retrouvé mort avec un
pistolet dans sa main et un magnétophone
à côté de lui
le détective appuyer sur le bouton play
et à écouter le message le message
disait je suis fatigué de cette vie et
j'ai décidé de dire adieu à ma douleur
et la souffrance suivi d'un son de coups
de feu le détective ne croit pas à
l'hypothèse du suicide
pourquoi la détective pense-t-il que
c'était un meurtre
[Musique]
ah ok j'ai la solution ce que vous voyez
à côté du corps ce n'est pas du tout un
magnétophone c'est un poste de radio à
l'ancienne quand l'enquêteur est arrivé
sur les lieux du crime et il se trouve
que cette radio envoyez de la musique
celle des black eyed peas qui s'appelle
l'aide des leafs are said les dialyses
certaines qui veut dire laissons le
commencer les sur le comment c'est quoi
l'enquète de qui parle-t-il de
l'enquêteur tout cela n'est qu'un jeu
l'homme allongé n'est pas mort il s'agit
d'un mannequin salle enquêteurs n'en
sait rien puisqu'il a pas médecin
légiste tout cela avec une vulgaire mise
en scène de la part de quelqu'un qui
soit de jouer avec la police sans tuer
personne c'est bon réponse si l'homme
s'est suicidé comment aurait-il pu
rembobinez la cassette jusqu'au début la
réponse est oui
ouais mec nous on est trop jeune pour ça
moi le magnétophone j'ai cru que c'était
un lecteur de cd m'annoncer c'est un
lecteur de cd il aurait dit lecteur de
cd je cherche des excuses
voilà c'est bon bravo à tous ce qu est
la bonne réponse encore une fois pour
être honnête
pour sûr ça j'ai pas trop réfléchi pas
fait d'effort allez on y va mystère de
noël un détective mettait en garde
pendant les vacances de noël et le matin
du 25 décembre il a reçu un appel et
s'est rendu chez quelqu'un il a sonné à
la porte et une minute plus tard un
propriétaire de maison ou encore à
moitié endormi a ouvert cette dernière
le détective a dit votre voisin indiqué
hier lors du réveillon de noël
il est venu chez vous pour faire la fête
et pendant qu'ils étaient là vous êtes
rentré dans sa maison et vous avez volé
des objets de valeur battu un cépage en
tue soit je vous prêtez a répondu ce
n'est pas vrai notre famille a célébré
le réveillon de noël chez des amis nous
avons à peine eu le temps de décorer
notre arbre de noël
le détective a déclaré pas d'inquiétude
il est assez évident pour moi que votre
voisin est un menteur comment le
détective savait-il
[Musique]
bon cette fois j'ai la solution d'impôt
devrait j'ai vraiment réfléchi si le
réveillon du voisin de cet homme c'était
bel et bien passé chez cet homme
on est d'accord qui aurait eu du monde u
rue beaucoup de déchet beaucoup de
débris en tous cas chez cet homme le mec
vient tout juste de se lever l'un du
matin il est déphasée les dégâts alors à
quel moment exactement aurait-il eu le
temps de ranger tous les débris de la
fête
à aucun moment il est donc évident que
le voisin mans et que le réveillon n'a
jamais eu lieu chez cet homme là la
chaussure j'ai bon les gars lumineuse de
l'arbre de noël sont débranchés et le
manque d'ailleurs une ampoule elle ne
fonctionnerait pas sans l 1 il était
clair pour détective que propriétaire
c'est la vérité il avait décoré le sapin
avec tellement précipitations qui
n'avait même pas vérifié s'il ya un an
2009 fonctionner ou non c'est
complètement la merde mais beck haas
encore plus simple de prouver le truc
avec ma théorie un mois il est crevé
vient de se lever le gars est genre chez
lui tout est nickel ranger en bref c'est
chiant explique jean paul giroud s'est
mieux tenu que la guerre entre bravo à
ceux qui ont eu raison et je pense
qu'ils sont 0 qui est la mère la mère
teresa regarde l'image
ouais je regarde berlin il ya deux ans
dans une pièce qui sont assises l'une en
face de l'autre tandis qu'un petit
garçon joue par terre qui selon toi est
la vraie mère de l'enfant
celle de gauche parce que l'enfant il en
train de jouer vers la meuf de gauche
voilà c'est l'explication das réponse
la mère de l'enfant et la dame à gauche
elle est assise avec ses jambes diriger
vers l'enfant c'est exactement ce que
j'ai dit mais dans l'autre sens l'enfant
diriger vers la maman hutin je partis
que le fbi haribo la posture de la femme
à gauche et protectrice légèrement
incliné vers l'avant il est naturel pour
les petits enfants de faire face à leur
mère si elle est là lorsqu'ils jouent ou
font une activité
c'est exactement ce que j'ai dit oh non
c'est fini je suis dégoûté alors je peux
dire un truc je sais ma vidéo donc oui
façon déjà dans ce dernier truc c'est
vraiment de l'analyse du comportement et
ses ex vraiment dans la vraie vie
vraiment vous pouvez savoir un petit peu
les uns les intentions des gens juste en
analysant leurs comportements leurs
postures leur manière de bouger leur
gestuelle parce qu'inconsciemment on
envoie des tas de messages avec notre
corps involontairement voilà s'intéresse
très peu de jus
lassus jours le deuxième test pour
rejoindre le mba mba oui un serial
killer ouest en anglais se passe pour
les vl faut parler anglais et est du
coup notre anglais nick castle qui leur
a invité une future victime chez elle
ils ont mangé ensemble après quoi elle
lui a offert une pomme que la victime
ayant dit qu'elle n'avait plus fin le
tueur a coupé la pomme en deux pour
qu'il la partage
ok ils ont tous les deux commencé à
manger leurs morceaux de pommes mais
aussitôt l'inviter à manger la pomme
aussitôt elle est décédée pourquoi l'un
des deux est mort et l'autre a survécu
ok elles avaient éclaté les pépins en
petits morceaux de lancer de la mère de
ma théorie un ça y est je sais autsai et
je sais elle a empoisonné un seul côté
de la lame du couteau
du coup en coupe pour la pomme s'ajuste
empoisonné un côté de la pomme au mec je
suis sûr c'est ça c'est sûr j'ai la
bonne réponse
le tueur a utilisé un couteau qu'elle a
empoisonné seulement d'un côté de la
lame mecs jouent juste au mont d'or
c'est incroyable ok deuxièmement un
mystère chimiques ou vous avez vu l'âge
mais chauffage il aurait pu suivre la
cour des grands la cour des enquêteurs
oh [ __ ] un chimiste célèbre a été
retrouvé mort dans son laboratoire
la police avait que deux personnes
étaient impliquées dans le meurtre et il
y avait cinq suspects feliz joshua
nicolas nathan et peter la police a
trouvé note écrit par le chimiste 26 3
58 28 27 57 16 bat s'est dit ça c'est
des trucs du tableau des éléments faut
juste regarder à temps parce que non
mais tu as droit de faire ça pendant le
tsb a su vous en faites pas regarder
alors 26 3 58 feu
li se félicite 28 27 57 16 nico la voilà
donc c'est fini c'est nicolas bay mecs
vous dire un exercice de physique-chimie
de troisième gros scandale
c'est pas du tout pour allouer mais ok
troisième henning ses brames meurtre
chez soi un homme a été retrouvé mort le
dimanche après midi au moment le meurtre
a été commis il y avait quatre personnes
dans la maison quatre suspects
potentiels jackson la femme
le cuisinier la bonne et le charting
chacun a dit à la police qu'il était en
train de faire au moment du meurtre la
femme a dit j'étais en train de lire un
livre le cuisiner à 10 j'étais en train
de cuisiner un breakfast mais tu quand
il est mort c'était pas après le
breakfast alors théâtre cuisine est un
breakfast à une peur qui ne correspond
pas au moment où l'enjeu break parce tu
me prend pour un con je t'aime pas toi
la bonne a dit j'étais en train de
mettre la table et le jardinier a dit
j'étais en train d'arroser les plantes
qui est meurtrier et comment la police a
su alors déjà job vous travaillez tous
beaucoup
bien ce n'est pas vous aussi est
forcément l'un d'eux vous quai camille
tôt et qu'ils étaient en train de faire
autre chose que ce qu'ils devaient faire
c'est un voyou savez quoi franchement je
la joue dans les temps et tous il
cuisine et je sens pas un homme et une
cuisine pas il était trop tard pour
cuisiner c'est sûr tu vois pourquoi
enquêter quand à l'instinct ça passe le
cuisine elle a fait tu ne cuisine pas le
déjeuner dans l'après-midi bah oui tu
cuisines avant mais j'aurais dû mettre
dans le titre pour les moins de 7 ans la
sur celui-là argent volé oui j'écoute
bien sûr encore les mêmes c'est le
cuisiner c'est le cuisinier c'est sûr
c'est toujours lui un homme a mis un
billet de 100 dollars sur une table puis
est allé travailler quand il est revenu
la monnaie avait disparu il a trois
suspects le cuisiner la bonne et
l'électricien le cuisiner a dit j'ai
mille billets sous un livre pour le
mettre en sécurité la bonne a dit j'ai
mis le billet dans livres entre la page
10 et 11 pour le mettre en sécurité
non mais attends non mais déjà il a tous
ces gens là chez lui le billet tu peux
le mettre sur la commande en évidence
ils sont pas sensibles de le voler deux
qui sont pas censés te le mettre en
sécurité adopte un billet un gros
problème de confiance là entre ces gens
on est d'accord on reprend l'homme a
checké dans le livre y avait rien entre
la page 10 et 11
l'électricien a dit j'ai vu le billet
sortir un peu du livre et je les bouger
entre la page 11 et 12 pour le maintenir
en sécurité il ya un gros problème dans
cette maison bon on récapitule le
cuisiner il a pris le billet il a mis
sous le livre la bonne elle a vu le
billet alors qu'il est toujours comment
est ce qu'elle a vu le pied
alors qu'il était sous lui l'abonné
coupable voilà bah moi je fais au flair
vous allez voir regarder je me trompe
jamais en plus vers des mers vous allez
voir bon un électricien une bonne
franchement ça semble un peu déjà déjà
non pour ma défense a oui je suis débile
en gros ouais je vous explique ouais ça
ces signatures dans l'art et non mais
voilà pourquoi je dise page 11 le biais
page 11 pages 12 comment tu caches entre
ces deux bases
j'arrive particules aujourd'hui au quai
[ __ ] c'est la dernière énigme de la
vidéo le fbi a et m'a dit que si on pas
celle ci on peut rejoindre ses rangs
alors on se concentre s'il vous plaît du
froid sur les fenêtres
c'est le nom ban a été retrouvé mort
dans son étude par son ami john john a
alors appelé la police et leur a dit ce
qui s'était passé il a dit j'ai vu une
lumière qui venait de sa chambre
j'ai décidé d'aller voir dehors s'il
était là il y avait du givre sur la
fenêtre alors je les ai essuyé et c'est
là que j'ai vu le corps j'ai alors
enfoncé la porte de la pièce pour
vérifier ce que j'avais vu et je suis
tombé sur le corps de mon ami j'ai
immédiatement appelé la police
l'officier a immédiatement su que john
manthey comment il a su
[Musique]
j'ai la réponse lamy est coupable car
plutôt que d'appeler la police au moment
où il a vu le corps de son ami étendus
sur le sol
il a préféré entrer ce qui est
totalement illogique il aurait dû
appeler la police
avant nous allons peut-être jean-noël
bien
le gif d'une fenêtre se forme du côté
qu'il est à l'intérieur de la pièce et
non pas à l'extérieur jobs n'aurait donc
pas pu essuyer l'ogive pour voir son ami
les amis c'est la fin du test
j'espère que vous l'avez passé avec
succès ce n'est pas mon kart g1 bolchoï
oui c'est vrai bon bravo à cette chaîne
youtube qui a juste pris les énigmes qui
sont connues depuis huit ans mais qui a
eu l'ingéniosité de marquer test pour
rejoindre le fbi
ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas fait des
petits quizz qu'on n'avait pas fait
travailler les méninges ça a quand même
fait kiffer même c'est de la bonne
grosse comme grid gros bisous à très
vite puisque tu marques dans la fin d'un
sms que tu vois ta maman ça bref aux
énormes et laïcité reconnu et non je me
fatigue
[Musique]
sow